this short series will cover the grammar
of sentences the very basics of syntax
it will build on the introduction to
morphology where we looked at words and
pieces of words this time we're moving
from the form of words to the
arrangement of words I'll use the terms
grammar and grammatical in these lessons
but they're different than how you may
have heard them used in the past in
linguistics the clearest point of
comparison for what is grammatical would
be the speech of a native speaker of a
language not a set of judgments from a
grammarian or a teacher
that touches on a long-standing debate
in linguistics depending on your
perspective you might check if a
sentence is grammatical by asking a
native speaker to judge the sentence or
you might check against other examples
produced in that language instead a
simple way to conceive of grammar at
this point is to treat it as a set of
rules which allows you either to
accurately describe or produce sentences
in a specific language the first topic
we'll look at is a clause a clause is in
some ways a kernel sentence it usually
has a finite verb which means that the
verb reflects something about the
subject the doer of the action it
usually has tense or aspect some way of
indicating when or how the action takes
place clauses don't have to have a
finite verb a small clause is often
based around an infinitive an example of
a small clauses to go to the store and
that small clause might be embedded into
another clause we'll talk about
embedding later but one example is I
want to go to the store so want is the
finite verb in the main clause and the
main Clause can be I want it or in this
case I want to go to the store and
that's the main clause or the matrix
clause or the independent clause because
you will find it on its own
a dependent clause will often have some
introductory word like that or if and
this allows you to identify the clause
as needing to be put within another
clause in order to form a complete
sentence
this has been a very simple introduction
to dependent clauses and independent
clauses but keep these in mind as we
start to build more sentences in the
next lesson
you